hi guys today I'm gonna play a game for
you called Panchito chiapas champ
Panchito chiapas hi Tito Chavez from a
game studio called pin it on to padron
studios I think I'm saying this all
wrong but it's a mother basically they
got in touch with me and they said do
you wanna play demo and I was like okay
what is this looked into it and it looks
pretty cool it's all based around the
art style of like lucasarts where all
the monkey island stuff and stuff like
that so i thought i'd give it again next
pickle see harness Prince it's pointing
clicking oh the mayor has called he's
coming I can tell from the music it just
suppose you play monkey on it all over
again moffat shoes massive shoes oh
right inventory okay then class I'm
bread oh oh oh why did I do that
actually mr. lemon wake up or not cheese
geez pick it out OIC to go pick up
cheese for me talk time is the line
hello my name is Panchito Japan my mom
helped me I have just the thing for you
sir red
something is missing in the menu you
want manly my ass I hate them such a
girl pick up the rathole talk to the
brattle mad bad spent eternity the hell
will you pick up the pillow he says I'm
not a pervert it doesn't even make sense
why why he do that make up a pillow on a
pervert I don't get that
what did you say I was like okay right
the human species lemon I've lactose
intolerance he what's a need I feel
tougher oh yeah a rat
what the why did I do that
get out rat I want to see our pride am
actually work okay now we can add a rat
city one at me right all right
presentation oh yeah Nelson student is
terrible love that's nice surat sandwich
whew he enjoyed it that's disgustin okay
so now what do we do mr. lemon hello my
name is punching dirty bass you've
already told me that don't see very
clever but I just got you that rat
summer at night or you fed me who
deserved my sympathy exactly my name is
Franklin book or knock wood Allah which
builder great ah you smell of lemons mmm
gin and lemon great I like your mustache
is it 11 and I can do I want it for me
yeah I don't think I like you
okay what are you doing here I was
saying in a way even you will understand
alcohol right time you've been here he
put me in here yesterday as soon as a
man finds out there what release me what
is so lucky what is in the so much it's
a rat delicious flat stomach I have
eaten raw you're so lucky it's dying
devil spawn the door was more polite of
you oh no he died he really stinks of
lemon even in death that's nice hmm um
pick up mr. lemon he has an elegant
massage yes take his mustache an
appointed one haha oh now he's mr. lemon
now I just need to dispose of the air
evidence oh I'm sorry mr. mayor there
are no excuses for him if you always
keep a job shouldn't take action on your
own but the inspector coming para amar
said sure I was a care of the inspector
you take care of getting my bridge
builder out of jail where he should
never have been yes mr. mayor I'm sorry
mr. mayor
we doin it really smells like lemon oh
my god is something there so Danny is
your cute is it Davey look right in you
okay Franklin ah you know me pretty well
you can call me Frankie hahaha let's go
Frankie good you next to say good and
great and lemons a perder Oh The Sun has
never stopped shining since I've been
something jia hua Jiao oh my mr i was
reading the jail sign yes I didn't make
you caught only because of that Wow
let's go for a walk ok so can I sit all
western town that we're in oh oh my gosh
the but it has changed a lot since we
pursue girls together with a bottle of
our hands bottles of our hands and head
out the thing is like that the gold
mines gold is over gold I'm super
pleased yes you know as well as I do
that it's always been the engine of our
town so that pause gold town merchants
don't want to travel 200 miles to come
here
if they can't go back home with their
carts full of gold ingots oh I get it we
have tried with money but it runs out
faster me work so that they're getting
money like woman instead of money or is
that just like irrelevant joke so month
ago we sent some to you go browse it up
for new gold mines three months pass
before they came back so take oh well
it's useless as ever does you you're
pretty dumb the point is that they found
a minor the other side of the river come
here oh there it is that's the reason
why I made you come here you will build
a bridge to bring all the gold here oh
nice build a bridge now you can go off
it like the use of Sun nope but if only
but in fact only vowel come back alive
it's a long and treacherous route which
country girl foot you haven't changed a
bit Frankie so here's a useless [ __ ]
builder anyway
where'd you have the blueprints I wanted
you to bring yeah those of your last
bridge I want one just like that wide
and strong where are they well of course
you wouldn't go out partying up with
them on you right where are you staying
I don't in your house I sit in your
house in your house I remember in your
uncle's house fire hounds I've got
things to do bring them later to my
office so all I have to do is build a
stupid bridge to get all that belt but
first I have to find this pretty prints
to show them that I wanna laugh um
blueprints go
I talked to him letter nice you start
waking up let's just give up now now to
the work oh [ __ ] this up i like those
boxes with the pants on them the pads on
the harrison oh my god shooting up
here's your spinner um Oh option three
in hotel was being watched by monster
master gggg you're so funny timing let
me know if you need something wow she
has one cubo de wonder oh ah he's so
cute I just enjoy him do not enter for a
few hours why it's been oh so you know
what let's go anywhere that she's
cleaned all that makes perfect sense not
what great tits you also look more
handsome than usual uh what's your
favorite animal he wants to ask everyone
that she likes Tigers should say here
I'm not a tiger oh you're fired Oh
which I was very boring grace is going
now stop flirting with her you just told
her you're not Tiger ah and that is how
you sure to continue okay what the hell
are you doing in my house oh yeah where
is my uncle he's sleeping where are the
blueprints I imagine I'll go hits
mobsters I'd imagine see them right now
don't even think about going upstairs a
disclaimer honey oh sorry imagine but it
wasn't idler no well done since he
finished designing a great town all your
uncle rest day and night I would give
that lady Basset of hiding a real hiding
Jessie's dude kinky you look very
masculine talking about that darling oh
yeah stop so actually with me after
weird okay um I'll come back later yeah
get out
Oh Joey go turn this door is closed oh
my gosh the prism good and square whoa
bust statue man on a horse it's too
heavy obviously it's too happy will you
read it well van deauville now in
traditional hard and conquers enough
that poor donkey like it's hot as well
take the hat I find Quentin taste the
city with suspect ok can we like talked
to him talked to the donkey drive it
talks
ah where does that long time face come
from everything is okay no no wait tell
me my friend my life is no longer what
it was the village is gone
this is not what we promised what do
they promised you a new mayor hasn't
delivered anything like what his father
promised can you believe that when he
had only just begun his mandate he
wanted to go plate the town hall what a
scary no one's like me he will be
calling cards for generations so this
miserable thing appears selfish road
layabout wicked potato old crock
Hellenistic slave trader misogynist
Hagler boom boom bad leg where is this
crystal and all these words to your
vocabulary now let's just run away okay
30 go into City Hall today what oh no I
better don't you leave that so much
hatred you've got to Mexico Jimmy here
you are not a zero Mexican accent I
can't do it
from this dash dude he won't change his
voice I the same as always there oh I'm
not doing it not again the possum on a
prophecy animal so mean my wife and I
came from beyond the border it's very
rough journey I remember one do it what
you don't remember the last time you
showered some of these jokes are red I
like the donkey down who is pig I
forgive me sir to her why you're
cleaning it I have to do it man since
the facade must be shining how I see so
say okay whatever I have a better job
than you I'm a [ __ ] / older grilled
over oh my god oh come on do that
it's a good job but I don't want any
problems with the authorities ah what
about camp pimpin awful zone no I guess
furious oh yeah should we go into a
brothel okay I'll face up to your master
no sir and what will I live on you don't
dare I didn't say that it's just that
are you afraid please they don't push it
ChIP chip chip chip I think its first be
like [ __ ] cluck cluck like a chicken aah
everyone look at your gear how dare you
step into my place ever why'd you did
last night oh I see listen to be faintly
don't call me far away again yeah oh
there goes his hopes and dreams this
time more ladies are sleeping all right
oh right it was man oh I see so that's
all I've got time for at the moment I
just wanted to show you this really cool
game it looks really cute and it's quite
funny as well let me know if you want me
to carry on playing and also check them
out there on IndieGoGo right now so the
link will be in the description that
lovely do you think bye I don't like
places like this made you mad right
places like this
what the puppy how come from no